GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE, WE HAVE
A FEW ITEMS. 13 ITEMS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY, AND WE WILL START.
IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO, ASSISTANT, WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL? SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. HERE. WILK.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. HERE. DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. HERE LAIRD. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. Ã WITH OUR QUORUM.
LET'S MOVE TO OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR, SO WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
VOTE ON THAT ASSISTANT. WILL YOU
CALL THE ROLL? BEFORE WE GET A
MOTION FROM ONE OF THE MEMBERS,
I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO CONSENT TODAY. FILE
ITEMS NUMBER TWO AND NUMBERS
FIVE THROUGH 12. DO WE HAVE A
MOTION? SO MOVED. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUSSO, ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I. DURAZZO DURAZZO I.
LAIRD. WITH A VOTE OF 3 TO 0,
THE CALENDAR IS ON CALL, AND WE
WILL GO A BIT OUT OF ORDER
TODAY. HEARING BILLS. WE'LL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER 13. SINCE I SEE THE
GOOD ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL
WITH US, WE'LL START WITH AB
3143. MR. LOWENTHAL, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. IS
THIS HOT? OKAY. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 3143, WHICH PREVENTS
AN EMPLOYER FROM PROHIBITING OR
IMPLEMENTING A POLICY TO
PROHIBIT AN EMPLOYEE OF A
RESTAURANT FROM RECEIVING A
GRATUITY. A GRATUITY THAT IS
PAID, GIVEN TO, OR LEFT FOR AN
EMPLOYEE BY A PATRON. TIPPING IS
EMBEDDED IN OUR CULTURE AT THE
MAJORITY OF RESTAURANTS WE
FREQUENT. WE EXPECT TO BE
PROMPTED TO LEAVE A TIP AT THE
SERVICE KIOSK FOR OUR MORNING
COFFEE OR ON OUR CHECK FOR
DINNER. WHILE TIPPING HAS BECOME
COMMONPLACE THROUGHOUT MUCH OF
THE FOOD SERVICE INDUSTRY, THERE
ARE STILL SOME RESTAURANTS THAT
MAINTAIN POLICIES TO PREVENT
THEIR EMPLOYEES FROM ACCEPTING
GRATUITIES. MANY FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS RELY ON TIPS TO MAKE
ENDS MEET, ESPECIALLY FOR
EMPLOYEES EARNING MINIMUM WAGE,
AND POLICIES TO PREVENT TIPPING
ARE HURTING THESE EMPLOYEES.
POLICIES TO PREVENT EMPLOYEES
FROM RECEIVING OR ACCEPTING TIPS
ARE MOST COMMON AMONGST CHAINS.
DESPITE THE LEGISLATORS SUCCESS,
TO RAISE THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
FAST FOOD WORKERS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE COMBINATION OF LOW WAGES AND
BENEFITS, OFTEN COUPLED WITH
PART TIME EMPLOYMENT, MEANS THAT
MANY OF THE FAMILIES OF FAST
FOOD WORKERS MUST RELY ON
TAXPAYER FUNDED SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS TO MAKE ENDS MEET. SO
NOT ONLY ARE THE POLICIES THAT
PROHIBIT TIPPING HURTING FOOD
SERVICE, EMPLOYERS, IT'S ALSO
HURTING TAXPAYERS BY ALLOWING
FOR TIPPING IN ALL RESTAURANTS.
AB 3143 ALLOWS FOOD SERVICE
EMPLOYEES TO EARN A CRITICAL
SOURCE OF INCOME, AND TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS CLOSING
THE WAGE GAP EXPERIENCED BY
UNDERSERVED AND MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN THESE LOW WAGE JOBS IN THE
FOOD SERVICE INDUSTRY. THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE. IT'S LONG
OVERDUE. IN ORDER TO CREATE
PARITY FOR ALL FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY SO MUCH. MR. LOWENTHAL,
DO YOU HAVE WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
TODAY? OKAY. SEEING NO WITNESS,
IS ANY ANYONE HERE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY?
PLEASE COME TO THE MIC, STATE
YOUR NAME. ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE ROOM? SEEING NONE.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS
MEMBERS, WELL, I'LL MOVE THE.
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO. I CAN MOVE
THE BILL, BUT I LOVE THE STORY
YOU TOLD ME ON THE WAY OVER HERE
AS TO WHAT PROMPTED YOU AND TO
DO THIS. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING OUT FOR OUR
TIPPED CLASSIFICATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR RUSSO,
WHO HAS MOVED THE BILL. I THINK
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
SYSTEM. WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL?
OH, WILL YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, MR.
LOWENTHAL, RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE YOU. ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER 13, AB 3143. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK
CORTEZ. A CORTEZ I. YES, SIR.
WHERE ARE WE ON. ON. OUT OF
ORDER. ALL RIGHT, WHICH I COULD
HAVE BEEN HERE TO HEAR
TESTIMONY. SO I'M GOING TO LAY
OFF AS OF RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE I
MADE SURE OF IT, SO I APOLOGIZE.
I HAD TO GO. OKAY, I'LL GET
EDUCATED FOR THIS. CORTEZ. I
DURAZZO, DURAZZO I LAIRD. OKAY.
THAT BILL IS ON CALL WITH A VOTE
OF 3 TO 0. AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
WILL VOTE WHEN THEY RETURN.
THANK YOU, MR. LOWENTHAL.
THANKS, MR. I COULD LIE, I.
OKAY. WE HAVE SENATOR DURAZZO
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA FOR A
AB 1870. OH, I'M SORRY, NOT THAT
ONE. AB 3234. OKAY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, AS YOU SAID, I'M,
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIZ ORTEGA A BILL THAT
SIMPLY REQUIRES COMPANIES WHO
VOLUNTARILY UNDERGO A SOCIAL
COMPLIANCE AUDIT TO POST THOSE
FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT RELATING
TO CHILD LABOR TO THEIR WEBSITE.
A SOCIAL COMPLIANCE AUDIT IS A
NON-GOVERNMENTAL AUDIT BY A
PRIVATE FIRM THAT REVIEWS A
FACILITY TO ENSURE THAT AN
EMPLOYER IS COMPLIANT WITH ALL
APPLICABLE CHILD LABOR LAWS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY,
ALLOWING CONSUMERS TO SUPPORT
COMPANIES THAT FOLLOW CHILD
LABOR LAWS AND COMPANY
SHAREHOLDERS TO KNOW HOW THEY
ARE PERFORMING AND WHERE THEY
MAY NEED TO IMPROVE. WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
BARRASSO, DO YOU HAVE A WITNESS
WITH YOU TODAY? OKAY, LET'S SEE.
WE'LL GO TO THE ROOM. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY? PLEASE STEP
FORWARD. OKAY. SEEING NONE,
ANYONE SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL TODAY. OKAY. WE WILL
COME TO THE DAIS. I WILL MOVE
THE BILL. DO YOU HAVE A MOTION?
SO MOVED. OH, I. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR CORTESE.
ASSISTANT. WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE,
AB 3234. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WILK
A WILK. I CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I. LAIRD. OKAY.
WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 0, THIS BILL
IS ON CALL. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
OKAY. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OFF CALL SO
THAT SENATOR WILK CAN VOTE.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR, WHICH
IS FILE ITEMS NUMBER TWO, AND
ALSO FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH 12.
SENATOR WILK WILK I, SENATOR
LAIRD. SO WE HAVE A VOTE OF 4 TO
0 ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'LL
PUT IT BACK ON CALL, IT LOOKS
LIKE WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
PRESENTERS, SO WE WILL RECESS
COMMITTEE UNTIL THE PRESENTERS
SHOW AND COME BACK HOPEFULLY IN
THE NEXT 5 OR 10 MINUTES. I
AND LABOR COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. SEEING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORA IN THE ROOM. WE ARE READY
TO PROCEED, AB 1516. READY WHEN
YOU ARE ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT
AB 1516, WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY TO CONVENE A WORKING
GROUP TO STUDY AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON RAISING THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND ENDING THE SUB
MINIMUM WAGE FOR INCARCERATED
WORKERS. THE WORKING GROUP WOULD
BE COMPRISED OF STATE
REPRESENTATIVES, ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING LOW WAGE OR
IMMIGRANT WORKERS, ORGANIZATIONS
ADVOCATING FOR THE RIGHTS OF
INCARCERATED PERSONS, AND AN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
EMPLOYERS. THE GROUP'S FINAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE WILL
GUIDE LAWMAKERS IN ENACTING A
STATE MINIMUM WAGE THAT TRULY
REFLECTS WHAT WORKING FAMILIES
NEED TO MAKE ENDS MEET. WE KNOW
THAT WORKERS OF COLOR ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PAID THE
MINIMUM WAGE AND THESE WORKERS
DESERVE A LIVING WAGE THAT CAN
LIFT THEM OUT OF WORKING POVERTY
. EVEN WORSE, INCARCERATED
WORKERS WHO DO THE SAME WORK AS
OTHER WORKERS, INCLUDING
FIGHTING SOME OF OUR WORST
WILDFIRES, ARE PAID CONSIDERABLY
LESS THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE. THIS
ARCHAIC PRACTICE, WITH ITS
LEGACY FROM SLAVERY, MUST STOP
AB 1516 WILL LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR CRITICAL DISCUSSIONS AROUND
ANY FUTURE MINIMUM WAGE REFORM.
THE BILL CURRENTLY HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARE SARU
JAYARAMAN, PRESIDENT OF ONE FAIR
WAGE, AND JOHN CANNON, OUTREACH
COORDINATOR WITH LEGAL SERVICES
FOR PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITNESSES.
PLEASE HAVE A SEAT AT THE TABLE.
ALL RIGHT. I'LL GET UP AND GO
BACK. Þ DO YOU WANT ME TO STAND?
NO. ALL RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU
SO MUCH, ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARL AND
ALL OF YOU FOR HEARING US OUT.
I'M WITH ONE FAIR WAGE OR
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF 300,000
RESTAURANT AND SERVICE WORKERS.
1000 RESTAURANT OWNERS ALSO
TEACH AT UC BERKELEY AND HAVE
WRITTEN FIVE BOOKS ON THE ISSUE,
AND HAVE SOME, IF ANYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO READ ABOUT THE
BACKGROUND. BUT I'M HERE ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIVING
WAGE FOR ALL COALITION, WHICH IS
35 ORGANIZATIONS OF ECONOMIC,
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND GENDER
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS ALL
WORKING TO RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE IN CALIFORNIA CLOSER TO THE
COST OF LIVING AND END THAT VERY
LAST SUB MINIMUM WAGE FOR
INCARCERATED WORKERS. IT DOES
INCLUDE NOW THE UAW, THE UNITED
AUTO WORKERS, AND WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH SEIU. SO WE ARE
EXPERIENCING A POST-PANDEMIC
MOMENT IN WHICH WORKERS ARE
DEMANDING A LOT MORE FROM
RESTAURANTS. 1.2 MILLION WORKERS
WALKED OFF THE JOB IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY. THOUSANDS
OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE HAD TO
RAISE WAGES TO RECRUIT STAFF. WE
NEED A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD THAT
WOULD BRING ALL WORKERS UP
CLOSER TO THE COST OF LIVING,
WHICH HAS SKYROCKETED POST
PANDEMIC AND ALLOW WORKERS TO
COME BACK TO WORK IN THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND OTHER
LOW WAGE SECTORS. WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING THIS AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. WE ARE
LEADING INITIATIVES IN
WASHINGTON, MINNESOTA. WE HAVE
AN $18 INITIATIVE ON THE BALLOT
IN ARIZONA. IN WASHINGTON STATE,
TUKWILA AND RENTON ALREADY
PASSED 20 FOR ALL KINGS COUNTY,
WHICH INCLUDES SEATTLE, ALREADY
PASSED 20 FOR ALL. WE'RE
ACTUALLY BEHIND ON THIS ISSUE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, MINNESOTA
AND MASSACHUSETTS ARE BOTH
MOVING $20 BILLS RIGHT NOW, AND
WE AS CALIFORNIA, IF YOU LOOK AT
THE MIT LIVING WAGE CALCULATOR
STATEWIDE, WE'RE AT $44 AN HOUR
FOR ONE PERSON AND A TWO PARENT,
TWO CHILD HOUSEHOLD TO COVER
JUST THE BASICS. AND IT'S HIGHER
IN SAN FRANCISCO. IT'S $48 AN
HOUR TO COVER THE BASICS. EVEN
IN MODOC COUNTY, THE CHEAPEST
COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA, IT'S $35
AN HOUR. SO WE ARE, OF COURSE,
VERY HAPPY THAT FAST FOOD
WORKERS GOT $20 AN HOUR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT. KUDOS TO
SEIU AND THE FAST FOOD WORKERS.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN IN AGREEMENT
WITH US THAT NOW WE NEED THIS
FOR EVERYBODY, BECAUSE WORKERS
ACROSS THE LOW WAGE SECTOR ARE
SAYING IF FAST FOOD WORKERS CAN
GET 20, WE ABSOLUTELY NEED THAT
TOO. WE CANNOT HAVE 1650 IN A
STATE NEXT DOOR TO ARIZONA WITH
THREE TIMES THE COST OF LIVING
IN ARIZONA BEING AT 20 AND
WASHINGTON STATE BEING AT 20. WE
NEED A LIVING WAGE FOR
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING
INCARCERATED WORKERS WHO, AS
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR, HAVE BEEN
LEFT OUT ALL ALONG AND YOU DON'T
NEED TO TAKE IT FROM US, YOUR
OWN LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RELEASED A REPORT TWO MONTHS AGO
SAYING THE MINIMUM WAGE IS TOO
LOW. AND VERY HEARTBREAKINGLY,
MINIMUM WAGE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NO LONGER ABLE TO
AFFORD TO HAVE CHILDREN, GIVEN
THE VERY HIGH COST OF LIVING. SO
WE WANT CALIFORNIA TO BE A
LEADER, NOT A FOLLOWER. IN THIS
MOMENT. WE'RE A FOLLOWER. WE'RE
SO GRATEFUL THAT WE CAN, AT
LEAST STUDY THE ISSUE TO GET
CLOSER TO WHERE WE ARE. AND I
WANT TO THANK JOHN AND OUR
MEMBERS FOR COMING TODAY. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS JOHN CANNON.
I'M THE OUTREACH COORDINATOR
WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN, BUT
BEFORE HOLDING THIS POSITION, I
WAS IN PRISON FOR TEN YEARS AS A
FROM A YOUNG ADULT, FROM THE
MOMENT I ENTERED THE PRISON, I
WAS ASSIGNED JOB DUTIES,
INITIALLY, I WAS EXCITED TO GET
THESE JOBS BECAUSE I WOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR MY HYGIENE
PRODUCTS OR MY FOOD, OR SO I
THOUGHT. BUT, WHEN REALITY SET
IN, I WAS GIVEN DIFFERENT
POSITIONS. MY FIRST POSITION WAS
YARD LABOR, WHERE YOU'RE DOING
WORK OUTSIDE. MY SECOND POSITION
WAS WORKING IN THE KITCHEN. I
DID MAINTENANCE WORK, AND
EVENTUALLY I DID THREE YEARS
FIGHTING FIRES. AND, WILDFIRES
IN CALIFORNIA. FOR MAKING $0.08
AN HOUR FROM THE YARD LABOR JOBS
TO MY HIGHEST PAYING JOB WAS THE
FIREFIGHTING JOB WHERE I MADE A
DOLLAR AN HOUR. IT JUST WASN'T
ENOUGH TO EVEN BUY FOOD OR
HYGIENE PRODUCTS, IT BECAME
CLEAR I WAS GETTING EXPLOITED
FOR MY LABOR WHEN I COMMITTED MY
CRIME. I UNDERSTOOD THE
CONSEQUENCE. REYES I ACCEPTED
I'D BE CONFINED TO A PRISON CELL
AND SEPARATED FROM MY FAMILY,
WHO I LOVE DEARLY. BUT, BEING
EXPLOITED FOR MY LABOR IS NOT A
JUST CONSEQUENCE, MY CHILDREN,
THEY STILL NEEDED ME OUT HERE ON
THE OUTSIDE WORLD. ARE THERE.
ALTHOUGH I COULDN'T BE THERE
PHYSICALLY. ME BEING A FULL TIME
WORKER, I SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY AND
TAKE CARE OF MY KIDS STILL, EVEN
FROM IN THERE. SO EVEN TAXPAYERS
DIDN'T HAVE TO. UPON MY RELEASE,
I HAD NOTHING TO SHOW FOR THESE
YEARS OF HARD WORK. HAD I BEEN
PAID A LIVING WAGE, I WOULD HAVE
REENTERED SOCIETY AS A MORE
STABLE, PRODUCTIVE MEMBER. BUT
INSTEAD I FACED REENTRY WITH NO
MONEY, NOWHERE TO STAY. AND
THOSE SKILLS I LEARNED, DIDN'T
EVEN TRANSFER TO JOBS OUT HERE
BECAUSE I WASN'T ABLE TO GET
THOSE JOBS. IT SIGNIFICANTLY
HINDERED MY ABILITY TO REBUILD
MY LIFE. BUT BEING FORCED TO
WORK FOR LITTLE TO NO PAY GAVE
ME A DISTORTED VIEW OF THE
WORKFORCE. THE LACK OF FAIR
COMPENSATION LEFT ME FEELING
UNDERVALUED, DISILLUSIONED ABOUT
MY PLACE IN SOCIETY. EVERYONE
DESERVES A FAIR WAGE FOR THEIR
WORK, REGARDLESS OF THE
SITUATION. I COULD HAVE BEEN A
TAXPAYER AND I COULD HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PAY MY RESTITUTION AS
WELL. SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS
NOT JUST ABOUT FAIRNESS, BUT
IT'S ABOUT UPHOLDING HUMAN
RIGHTS AND CREATING SAFER
COMMUNITIES. SO I URGE YOU TO
HELP PASS THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU MUCH.
LOOKING IN THE ROOM NOW, IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE STEP TO THE MIC. STATE
YOUR NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. MELISSA MOORE. ALL OF
US ARE NONE IN SUPPORT, LOUIE
TADINI ONE FAIR WAGE IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WHO SPEAK WISH TO
SPEAK ON THIS BILL? OKAY. ANYONE
IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION WHO
WANTS TO GIVE COMMENT ON THIS
BILL? OKAY. SEEING NONE, WE'LL
MOVE TO MEMBERS. SENATOR RUSSO,
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. WELL, I
WANT TO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
ALL OF YOUR WORK ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE
MORE ELEMENT OF THE IMPACT OF
HAVING SUCH LOW WAGES, WHEN
YOU'RE UNEMPLOYED, YOUR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DEPENDS
ON WHAT YOUR WAGES WERE. SO THAT
, THAT HAS A BIG IMPACT. AND WE
COULD SEE THAT IN THE PANDEMIC,
PAID FAMILY LEAVE, YOU KNOW,
IMPACTED BY WHAT YOUR WAGES ARE,
EVEN LATER IN LIFE, SOCIAL
SECURITY, WHAT YOUR WAGES ARE,
HAVE AN IMPACT ON SO MUCH IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND ALMOST
CONDEMNS PEOPLE TO LIVE IN THAT
POVERTY FOREVER. SO I APPRECIATE
THIS. AND I WOULD GLADLY MOVE
THE BILL WHEN IT'S WHEN YOU'RE
READY, HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR RUSSO. SENATOR CORTESE,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I, TOO, WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR PUTTING
THIS TOGETHER. AND I WANTED TO
OF COURSE, THE WHOLE BILL IS
SOMETHING I SUPPORT, BUT, TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE SITUATION WITH
THE INCARCERATED, WHICH WE'VE
TRIED TO DEAL WITH OVER THE LAST
COUPLE SESSIONS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND WE'VE COME
CLOSE AND REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO DEAL WITH IT, I THINK
IT'S A TRAVESTY. I THINK IT'S
OBVIOUSLY IT'S A FORM OF MODERN
DAY SLAVERY AND JUST APPRECIATE
YOU. YOU COULD HAVE EASILY, YOU
KNOW, COME FORWARD WITH A BILL
WITHOUT THAT. MAYBE HAVE A
LITTLE EASIER PATH SOMEWHERE
ALONG THE LINE. I HOPE THAT'S
NOT THE CASE. I HOPE EVERYBODY
EMBRACES IT. BUT AGAIN,
APPRECIATE THAT ASPECT OF THE
BILL, ESPECIALLY. IT'S UP TO THE
CHAIR. I'LL, THAT'S ALL I HAVE,
MADAM CHAIR, IT LOOKS LIKE THE
WITNESS WANTS TO SPEAK, WE HAVE
ONE MORE MEMBER WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK. YES SO I'M SOMEBODY WHO
BELIEVES IN THE FREE MARKET, SO
I'M NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY. BUT WE
DO HAVE TO ADDRESS THE
COMPENSATION FOR THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR STORY. I'M SO SORRY
YOU WENT THROUGH THAT AND THAT.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST SO UNJUST.
IT'S JUST SO UNJUST. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU. SENATOR
WILK. YOU'RE WELCOME TO RESPOND
NO TO BOTH. I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MENTIONING
THAT BOTH OF YOU AND THE FACT
THAT IT'S BEEN HARD TO GET
ACROSS THE FINISH LINE, ONE OF
THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN MISSING IS
A FISCAL ANALYSIS, COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT DOESN'T JUST SHOW
THE COST TO THE STATE OF PAYING
INCARCERATED WORKERS A WAGE, BUT
THE TREMENDOUS SAVINGS THAT YOU
HEARD THAT COME FROM NOT HAVING
TO BE IN DEBT WHEN YOU COME OUT
IN TERMS OF RESTITUTION, PAYING
CHILD SUPPORT. SO WE ARE BOTH
WORKING WITH UC BERKELEY'S LAW
AND POLICY CENTER TO CONDUCT
SOME OF THAT INITIAL ANALYSIS
THAT WILL HELP FEED INTO THE
STUDY THAT THE STUDY BILL HELPS
TO CONDUCT. THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
BEEN MISSING ALL ALONG THAT WE
HOPE TO BRING TO YOU NEXT
SESSION. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
THANK YOU, MEMBERS, FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE MR. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
THE DAIS HERE, I SEE FOLKS THAT
I KNOW THAT HAVE WORKED ON THIS
ISSUE AND CARED ABOUT THIS ISSUE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME, AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
REGARDING WORKERS THAT CERTAINLY
NOT A FREE MARKET SYSTEM. WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT OUR INCARCERATED
WORKERS ARE TREATED. AND SO I
RESPECT THAT THOUGHT FROM
SENATOR WILK. AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALSO COMPLEX FOR BUSINESS
OWNERS. IF YOU DRIVE, YOU KNOW,
SAN JOSE, YOU DRIVE FOR 45
MINUTES. YOU CAN LITERALLY DRIVE
THROUGH SIX, SEVEN, EIGHT
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
MINIMUM WAGES, IT'S CONVOLUTED.
IT'S CONFUSING. I THINK THAT NOT
ONLY IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC JUSTICE, BUT I
THINK IN TERMS OF EFFICIENCY IN
CREATING AN ECONOMIC SYSTEM THAT
ACTUALLY MAKES SENSE. WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CARL, AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY AND RESPONSE. AND WITH
THAT ASSISTANT, WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR RAZA. WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE ITEM ONE AB
1516. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WILK. WILK. NÓ. CORTEZ CORTEZ I
DURAZO. DURAZO I. LAIRD. OKAY.
WITH THE VOTE OF 3 TO 1, THIS
BILL IS ON. CALL THE MEMBERS.
COME. WE'LL FOLLOW IT UP. THANK
YOU.
I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T THINK SO.
I WAS EMBARRASSED. OKAY. WE'RE
WAITING ON MEMBERS. SO THE LABOR
COMMITTEE WILL GO TO A SHORT
RECESS ABOUT TEN MINUTES, AND
WE'LL BE BACK WHEN THE MEMBERS
ARRIVE.
ALL RIGHT. I THINK THAT'S 30. I
THINK THAT'S 30S. SO WE WERE
GOING TO NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, AB EIGHT, 1890 BY
ASSEMBLYMAN JOE PATTERSON AND
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION OF Dð
PASS TO APPROPRIATE. AND WITH
THAT, THE FLOOR IS YOURS, SIR.
GREAT. WELL, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
, MR. CHAIR, I DON'T KNOW THE
DECORUM HERE. CALL YOU MR. CHAIR
WHILE YOU'RE CHAIRING THE
COMMITTEE, BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND SENATORS, GREAT. I AM
ASSEMBLYMAN JOE PATTERSON. NOT
TO BE CONFUSED WITH JIM
PATTERSON, BUT I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1890,
SPONSORED BY OUR FRIENDS HERE AT
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS. AND,
ESSENTIALLY WHAT IT DOES IS IT
REQUIRES NOTIFICATION OF DIR
WHEN THERE'S A CHANGE ORDER OF
$10,000 OR MORE. AND AS A FORMER
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER MYSELF, I
ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
THAT IN BRINGING THE
TRANSPARENCY TO CHANGE ORDERS
THAT OCCUR, ESPECIALLY ON LARGE
DOLLAR PROJECTS, WE WOULD OFTEN
GIVE SPENDING AUTHORITY TO THE
CITY MANAGER OF WHATEVER THE BID
WAS, PLUS 15% IF IT DID, IF THE
AMOUNT CAME IN BELOW 15, WE
HONESTLY WOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT IT.
IT DIDN'T MEAN WE DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO IT. BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU
GOT A LOT OF A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS GOING ON. SO WHEN I HEARD
ABOUT THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DO
THIS BILL, I WAS VERY INTERESTED
IN IT BECAUSE OF THE
TRANSPARENCY THAT IT PROVIDES
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO ARE PAYING
THESE BILLS AT THE END OF THE
DAY. SO SO I'LL LEAVE IT WITH
THAT AND I'LL TURN IT OVER HERE
WITH, MATT CREMEANS. HE'S WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE
OF THE OPERATING ENGINEERS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GREAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. MATT
CRIMMINS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEVADA CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS, WE ARE THE
PROUD SPONSORS OF AB 1890, WHICH
WILL PROVIDE NEEDED TRANSPARENCY
AROUND SITUATIONS IN WHICH
DETAILS OF PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
CHANGE AFTER THE PROJECT HAS
BEGUN. BY WAY OF BRIEF
BACKGROUND, EXISTING LAW
REQUIRES ALL AWARDING AGENCIES
OF PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS TO
NOTIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS OF ANY
CONTRACT THAT THEY INTEND TO
ENTER INTO WITHIN 30 DAYS OF
AWARDING THE CONTRACT, BUT NO
LATER THAN THE FIRST DAY IN
WHICH THE CONTRACTOR HAS WORKERS
EMPLOYED ON THE PROJECT, AND
THESE NOTICES ARE REQUIRED TO
CONTAIN A VARIETY OF INFORMATION
THAT'S INTENDED TO AID IN THE
ENFORCEMENT OF PUBLIC WORKS
LAWS, INCLUDING INFORMATION
RELATED TO CONTRACTORS AND
SUBCONTRACTORS, INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE ANTICIPATED
PROJECT, COST, INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE ESTIMATED START
AND COMPLETION DATE, AND ANY
OTHER INFORMATION THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER DEEMS APPROPRIATE
TO ASSIST WITH COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS. AND I WOULD NOTE AT THE
FRONT END HERE THAT SUBMISSION
OF THESE NOTICES IS DONE ONLINE
UNDER EXISTING LAW. AND THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S WEBSITE
ALREADY HAS THE ABILITY TODAY
FOR AWARDING AGENCIES TO UPDATE
THEIR PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
REGISTRATION. AND WHILE THESE
TAX WHILE THESE PUBLIC WORKS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE BEING
PROPERLY UTILIZED, AND THAT THE
LAWS THAT ACCOMPANY THESE
PROJECTS ARE BEING FOLLOWED,
EXISTING LAW IS SILENT ON
SITUATIONS IN WHICH DETAILS OF
THESE PROJECTS CHANGE AFTER THE
PROJECT HAS ALREADY BEGUN, AND
IN OUR MINDS, THIS LACK OF
CLARITY LEAVES THE DOOR OPEN FOR
UNLICENSED CONTRACTORS TO BE
ADDED ON TO PROJECTS AFTER THE
FACT, WITH THE PUBLIC AND THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER HAVING NO
KNOWLEDGE OF A CHANGE HAVING
OCCURRED. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID, AB 1890 SIMPLY SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS HAS FULL
AND ACCURATE INFORMATION RELATED
TO THE PROJECTS THAT THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO MONITOR,
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE AWARDING AGENCIES TO
UPDATE THEIR PROJECTS AND
SITUATIONS IN WHICH A CONTRACTOR
OR SUBCONTRACTOR IS APPROVED TO
BE CHANGED BY THE AWARDING
AGENCY, AND IT WOULD REQUIRE
THEM TO UPDATE DIR AND
SITUATIONS IN WHICH THEIR
PROJECT CHANGES BY $10,000 OR
MORE, ENSURING THAT DIR HAS UP
TO DATE INFORMATION RELATED TO
THESE PROJECTS WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT WORKERS ARE PROTECTED, AND
THAT THOSE PROJECTS AND THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE NOT GOING
TO CONTRACTORS WITH EGREGIOUS
LABOR VIOLATIONS. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS, AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE
TO ADD THEIR MEAT TO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL? JUST GO
TO THE MIC RIGHT OVER THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN,
MIKE WESSEL, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ELMER
LAZARD, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION, IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MARTIN VENDIOLA, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS, THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS,
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. NOW
WE HAVE OUR CLEANUP HITTER
COMING UP. Þ YOUR Tê WIENER.
OKAY, I WASN'T SURE IF I KIND OF
JUMPED THE GUN ON THAT. SASHA
HOROWITZ LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR THE
WE'VE WORKED OUT SOME AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT LOS
ANGELES AS A LEGACY LABOR
COMPLIANCE PROGRAM WITH A PLA,
IS ALREADY RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSEEING ITS OWN LABOR
COMPLIANCE QUESTIONS. AS THEY
COME UP, MEANING THIS WOULD BE
DUPLICATIVE FOR A PUBLIC AGENCY
LIKE OURS. SO THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE NOT IN PRINT, BUT WE HAVE A
COMMITMENT THAT THEY WILL BE.
AND WE THANK THE AUTHOR. GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE HERE
IN OPPOSITION? YOU'LL BE PRIMARY
. OKAY. WE HAVE 1 OR 2. WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE YOU TWO. I'M IN A
GOOD MOOD ACTUALLY. THEY TOLD ME
I HAVE TO GIVE YOU TWO. SO CAN
YOU BE IN A BAD MOOD THEN? IN
THIS ONE? I'M JUST KIDDING.
DAIMON CONKLIN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WANT TO, THANK THE
COMMITTEE, FOR THEIR WORK, THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR,
WORKING WITH US AND DESCRIBING
KIND OF THE CHALLENGES, THAT
THEY HAVE PERCEIVED WITH THE
INDUSTRY. THE INTENT, AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT, IS DESCRIBING
THIS KIND OF LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY FOR UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY AND ENSURING THAT LAW
ABIDING CONTRACTORS ARE ENGAGED
IN, PUBLIC WORK PROJECTS. WHAT
1890 DOES NOT DO, WHICH WE SEE
AS A DEFICIENCY IN THE BILL, IS
REQUIRED. DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO DO
ANYTHING WITH IT. CSLB IS THE
LICENSING BODY IN THE STATE,
DECIDES WHETHER A CONTRACTOR IS
HAS A SUSPENDED LICENSE OR
REVOKE LICENSE, IF THERE'S
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN DER AND
CSLB WITH SOME SORT OF
COLLABORATION WITH THIS
INFORMATION, I CAN SEE A GAP
BEING BRIDGED, BUT ALSO
PROTECTIONS FOR SUBCONTRACTORS
FROM BEING ARBITRARILY REPLACED
ON A, ON A PROJECT, THOSE ARE
ALREADY WELL PROTECTED IN THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE 4107, TO
ENSURE THAT SUBCONTRACTORS ARE
JUST NOT WILLY NILLY, YOU KNOW,
THROWN OFF A SITE, BUT ARE ONLY
DONE SO BECAUSE THEY'RE
UNLICENSED OR THEY HAVE SHODDY
WORK OR WHATEVER IT MAY BE, AND
SO AGAIN, ADDING A NOTIFICATION
OAN REQUIREMENT TO DER, WITH
THIS CHANGE DOESN'T WITH THAT
INFORMATION, DOES WHAT. SO
AGAIN, WE SEE SOME GAPS HERE,
ALSO 1890 ESTABLISHES A $10,000
CHANGE ORDER THRESHOLD. WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE THAT THRESHOLD CAME
FROM, THERE ARE SOME INDUSTRY
STANDARDS, CALTRANS HAS A
DIVISION OF CONSTRUCTION
APPROVAL THAT MUST REVIEW
PROJECTS, AND CHANGE ORDERS IN
EXCESS OF $200,000, IT'S A
COMMON PRACTICE. I DON'T KNOW
ABOUT THE CITY OF ROCKLAND, BUT
OTHER CITIES, AT LEAST HAVE A
FLAW WITH A PERCENTAGE THAT ARE
TIED TOGETHER. SO WE WOULD SAY
IF THERE'S A FLAW FOR, WITH A,
YOU KNOW, 20, 25, PERCENTAGE, I
THINK THAT WOULD BE SOMEWHAT IN
LINE OR CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE
SEE BY OTHER JURISDICTIONS. AND
WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED, GREAT.
ONLY 13 SECONDS OVER. THAT'S
GOOD. ARE YOU GOING TO DO IT
FROM THERE I CAN WHAT? WHEREVER
YOU'RE COMFORTABLE. THANK YOU.
CHAIR, ANTHONY TANNEHILL WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION, IN A SAME OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED WITH MY COLLEAGUE
ALSO WITH PORTFOLIO FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY. I ECHO THE SENTIMENTS AND
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE WHO
JUST SPOKE A LOT OF THE FEEDBACK
FROM MY MEMBERS, IS THAT WE'RE
ALL TRYING TO GET THESE PROJECTS
DONE, WE'RE ALL KIND OF ON THE
SAME TEAM THERE. WE NEED EACH
OTHER TO, TO DO THE PEOPLE'S
WORK AND BUSINESS. BUT THE
THRESHOLD OF $10,000 IS, COULD
COULD BE MANY HUNDREDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO RUN AFOUL OF
THIS, AND THE PENALTIES,
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
PROJECT, AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED,
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER ANALOGS
AND PROCEDURES, THAT SET THOSE
SORT OF TIMES THAT YOU NEED TO
AGENDIZE OR COME BACK TO YOUR
BOARD, YOUR ELECTED BOARD, OR
THINGS LIKE THAT. SO A FLOOR AND
A PERCENTAGE, MIGHT MAKE THE
BILL MUCH MORE MANAGEABLE FOR
OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS, AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE TIME
THAT'S LEFT TO ACHIEVE THAT.
THANK YOU. CHAIR SIR. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT WANTS TO
ADD A ME TO OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS. SENATOR
DURAZZO. YES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND, FOR
BRINGING THIS UP, MY QUESTION IS
RELATED TO THE THIS $10,000,
THRESHOLD THAT'S BEING DONE.
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR EXPERIENCE? I
MEAN, WHY PICK 10,000? IT SEEMS
VERY, VERY LOW, LIKE EXTREMELY
LOW. SO I'M, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE INDUSTRY TO BE
ABLE TO SAY THAT'S THE LEVEL
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO, YOU KNOW
, CARRY OUT WHAT THE WHAT THE
GOALS ARE. SO IF YOU CAN, EITHER
OF YOU OR BOTH OF YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE IT DOES SEEM I
DON'T KNOW HOW OFTEN IT
DEPENDING ON THE PROJECT, HOW
OFTEN CHANGE ORDERS DO COME UP,
MANY YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS AT THE
AIRPORT, COMMISSION CHANGE
ORDERS CAME UP A LOT, AND, BUT
USUALLY IT WAS A HIGHER AMOUNT.
SO IF YOU CAN SPEAK TO THAT, I
APPRECIATE IT. YES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I JUST WANT TO SAY,
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, THROUGH THE
COURSE OF THIS BILL, I'VE MET
WITH, MANY INDIVIDUALS, CITIES
ON IT, THAT IN MY VIEW, DOESN'T
HAVE THE SAME LEVEL OF CONCERNS,
BUT THAT SAID, I ALWAYS MEET
WITH OPPOSITION ON THE BILLS,
AND WE'RE AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE IT OUT, I WILL TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW THAT WE HAVE OFFERED A
10% INSTEAD OF $10,000, AND YOU
KNOW, THE RESPONSE WE GOT FROM
OUR OFFICE, FROM ONE OF THE
OPPONENTS WAS THAT IT'S HEADED
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. BUT TO
OTHER STAFF WAS THAT IT ACTUALLY
MADE THE BILL WORSE. SO I CAN'T,
YOU KNOW, NEGOTIATE WITH WHAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M LOOKING AT,
THAT SAID, I MET WITH ONE OF MY
CITIES ON FRIDAY AND THEY GAVE
ME SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS,
YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY ACTIONABLE
AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT, WE'RE
GOING TO WORK TOGETHER. AND BUT
BY THE WAY, WE OFFERED THE 10%
ON OUR OWN, ON OUR OWN, RIGHT
WHEN WE FOUND OUT THE
OPPOSITION, BECAUSE THIS WENT
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY ON CONSENT
AND, AND THE DAY I LEARNED OF
THE OPPOSITION WAS THE SAME DAY
THAT MY CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS
RECEIVED CALLS FROM FROM THE
ASSOCIATIONS AND, YOU KNOW, SO
I'M WILLING TO WORK ON THIS
MEASURE AND, AND CONSIDER THAT
FLOOR AS WELL AS, YOU KNOW, TO
MAKE SURE IT'S NOT TOO, YOU
KNOW, SMALL $5,000 OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. I MEAN, I'M TOTALLY
OKAY WITH THAT. SO MY THING IS,
I'M WILLING TO KEEP WORKING ON
THAT, TOTALLY OPEN TO IT. AND
BUT THE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT,
IN TERMS OF THE $10,000 NUMBER,
HE'D HAVE TO ANSWER THAT. THANK
YOU. NO, THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION, SENATOR, WE STARTED
WITH THE $10,000 THRESHOLD
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO BE SURE WE
WERE CAPTURING SMALLER PROJECTS
THAT COULD BE BELOW THE
APPRENTICESHIP THRESHOLD. SO
UNDER EXISTING LAW, APPRENTICES
ARE NOT REQUIRED ON PROJECTS
THAT ARE UNDER $30,000. SO WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
THRESHOLD WAS LOW ENOUGH WHERE
IF THERE WAS A $22,000 PROJECT
THAT RECEIVED A $10,000
INCREASE, THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER, THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER, COULD BE MADE
AWARE THAT THEN THEY ARE
EXPECTED TO ENFORCE
APPRENTICESHIP LAWS. BUT AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID, THIS IS A
STARTING POINT FROM OUR FROM OUR
END, WE HAVE ALWAYS BEEN HAPPY
TO WORK ON THIS THRESHOLD. WE
JUST HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN A
NUMBER FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT
WILL WORK ON THEIR END. YET
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. COMMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. IT
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S PROBABLY, A
SLIGHTLY MORE ELEGANT SOLUTION
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING ON IT. AND IN TERMS OF
WHAT'S NOT ARBITRARY, BUT, YOU
KNOW, A NUMBER THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
NOT GOING TO WORK ON OR MAYBE BE
UNNECESSARY IN SOME CONTRACT
SIZES, TOO LOW OR, YOU KNOW, BUT
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE REAL GOAL
HERE IS, IS TO JUST TO TRIGGER A
REVIEW WHEN YOU HIT $30,000. SO
MAYBE THERE'S A WAY TO
ESSENTIALLY JUST WRITE THAT
LANGUAGE INTO THE BILL, THAT
SAID, I'LL SUPPORT IT AND KEEP
IT MOVING ALONG IF WE CAN TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
CORTESE, DID WE GET A MOTION ON
THIS MOVE BY SENATOR WILKES
ASSISTANT, WHEN YOU CALL THE
ROLE, PLEASE CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON. OH, GREAT.
WELL HEY. THANK YOU, OBVIOUSLY,
THE PROPONENTS AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF AS WELL, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN'T GET THINGS
THROUGH THIS PLACE WITHOUT
WORKING TOGETHER AND VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO DO
THAT. AND WE WILL CONSIDER WE
WILL WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION,
EVEN WHEN IT PASSES THIS
COMMITTEE, TO SEE IF WE CAN COME
UP WITH SOMETHING THAT IS A
LITTLE BIT MORE TENABLE FOR
THEM. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR WILKES
ASSISTANT. WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR,
AB 1890. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WILK. WILK I CORTEZ. CORTEZ I
DURAZZO. DURAZZO I. LAIRD I.
LAIRD I. FIRST BILL TO GET OUT
ON THE FIRST TRY. 5 TO 0. THIS
BILL IS OUT. GREAT. THANK YOU.
AND ALSO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
PATIENCE GETTING ACROSS THE
STREET OVER HERE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. OKAY,
MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLL TO START WITH OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSISTANT WILL YOU.
ASSISTANT. WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR,
WHICH INCLUDES FILE ITEMS TWO
AND ALSO FILE ITEMS FIVE THROUGH
12, THE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. SENATOR LAIRD I LAIRD I. A
VOTE OF 5 TO 0. OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT NOW. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO AB 3134. ASSISTANT
I'M SORRY. AB 3234. ASSISTANT
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM THREE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATE. SENATOR LAIRD A
LAIRD I. OKAY. WITH A VOTE OF 5
TO 0, THAT BILL IS OUT NEXT, WE
WILL MOVE TO AB 1516. ASSISTANT
WILL YOU CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM ONE, AB 1516. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 1 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR LAIRD Ã
LAIRD I. Ã WITH A BILL OF FOR A
VOTE OF 4 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT
AND LAST, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
AB 3134 ASSISTANT. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON AB 3134. THE CURRENT
VOTE IS 3 TO 0 WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASSED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR WILK.
SENATOR. LAIRD. LAIRD I. I'M
GOING TO GO BEFORE SOMEBODY
DREAMS UP ANOTHER BILL. THANK
YOU. WITH A VOTE OF 4 TO 0, THAT
BILL IS OUT. AND THAT IS THE
FINAL ONE OF THE DAY. OKAY, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR TODAY,
THANKS, EVERYONE FOR THEIR
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY, PLEASE KNOW THAT YOU
CAN SUBMIT ANY TESTIMONY, IN
WRITING. AND WITH THAT, OUR
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.